[Music]
it's beginning to look a lot like [ __ ]
spritz okay slow down there think story
so I sat down and watched the last watch
an ironic name since it'll be the first
and last time I watch it unlike my last
video which was more serious and holy
[ __ ] guys thank you so much if you
watched it today we're just gonna have
some fun there will be tears memes and I
have hidden a Starbucks cup somewhere in
this video so if you find it let me know
in the comments I'm gonna make it hard
to find so keep your eyes peeled and
first of all before we begin I want to
send a huge thank you to the cast and
crew whose hard work and dedication made
this one of the most groundbreaking
seasons of television in terms of
production and design and we can't
forget the best extra in TV history
Andrew McClay the direwolf's a jealous
co-ed hardstark
fight for fame here we have the official
game of Thrones tapestry more work was
put into this than the season 8 story
can we also take a brief moment to
recognize the irony that the final
season was shot at titanic studios and
here's showrunner David Benioff telling
us what we can do with this season here
we have a brief glimpse of what a
typical day like is for one of the
producers you'll see we have the usual
6:00 a.m. Pilates class this woman has
the best job on the show throwing all
the scripts out and all these men are
dead on the show except for this guy
he's a writer we'll just fix that Oh
baby are ya mics plunged their knives
into him he takes more punishment than
Hodor took at the door then Barrack took
in the cardia bolts off a pile of dead
white sleeps at the night king and she
plunges the dagger up through the night
king's armor and a knight king shatters
so guys what do you think that's not
very I don't notice it pass charlie
best of my main breaking of chains and
mother track for a moment neither moves
as if moving will make this real we see
John with his hands still on the hilt of
the dagger
can we also just take a moment to
acknowledge director David nutters
assistant is strap is on nice do you
want any hang herbs and here we have a
shot of fans of season 8 here we have
Dave and Dan deciding which way the
script should go now I don't know why
they said they didn't have enough money
to include a ghost scene because this
puppet looks just like the real thing
although am I gonna get my uber try
saying this name three times fast these
guys are so bored on set they decided to
play tic-tac-toe ever wonder what it's
like to be an extra on Game of Thrones
no I mean yesterday had 250 extras and
all the crew and not one toilet in the
bowls the bleach was frozen come on
surely we can discuss something more
sanitary how do yo kill me the girl kill
knife King I know many times the stars
are joking with me and I think I need to
do nothing and here's a shot of the
Queen coming to kill the night king can
we also just take a moment to
acknowledge that the producers brought
in Jon Snow the waif and Jack and just
to throw the media off I would like to
see if that equals a nice one I am you
know
I you know who I am just going in for a
coffee
this set is just impressive as [ __ ] do
you know hopes and which means chicken
and lettuce on their bacon that's what
that is
I'm not sure this wigs got much more
life left in it
neither was the head underneath it there
any part of you that's have ever
relieved
yeah yeah
[Music]